man with power will be neither policy no
principle no one is different no one is
neutral if Superman were here what would
you want to say to him that my family
too had dreams to look him in his eye
and ask him how he decides which lives
count and which ones do not
there's a new kind of mean in him he is
angry and he's hunting
I didn't kill those men if that's what
they think
this is what makes you such a good
reporter stuff like this still shocks
I'm older now than my father ever was
this may be the only thing I do matters
so fools the house of way
God is all-powerful he cannot be
ultimate in the world only I sets you
force it to know like that words don't
stop you know what sucks in this
whatever God
that dream was all some people have it's
all that gives them hope no god is good
as dead
man made a world where standing together
is impossible we have to
and following people with great power
corrupts and absolute power corrupts
absolutely hey maybe he's just a guy
trying to do the right little better now
don't